ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Hello.
Welcome back to Devoxx 2013.
We're here right after
the Google keynote
with Lars and Kasper.
And welcome, guys,
and congratulations.
You've just announced Dart 1.0.
KASPER LUND: Sure did.
LARS BAK: Fantastic news.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Yeah, I know.
You've been working hard
on it, I'm pretty sure.
LARS BAK: We've spent the
last two and a half years
working on Dart.
So finally it's out, and it
seems like it's well received.
It's a fantastic new platform
for writing web applications.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Right.
So give me the big
picture in terms
of what it's trying to
do, the fact that it's not
just a language, probably,
the elevator pitch.
LARS BAK: The elevator pitch?
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yes.
It's going to be
short, first floor.
LARS BAK: We only
get one [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Moving up.
LARS BAK: The only
thing we want is
to make a program that's
more efficient way when
they write web applications.
And today, there's
currently some obstacles.
We think the language
is not structured enough
for writing big applications,
lacking of tools.
And we're trying to
solve that with Dart.
And so Dart is a combination
of a programming language,
a rich set of consistent
libraries, an IDE.
And then we have
the final piece.
We have Chromium
with Dart VM support.
So that means that when
you do development,
if you change the code,
you can try it right away.
So no lag in tools
when using it.
It
KASPER LUND: I think
it's worth adding
that in addition to having
that native way of running
Dart code, you can also compile
Dart to JavaScript and run it
across today's browsers.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Which would be probably--
so you're talking about the
developer use case, which
is as fast as possible
of a round trip,
so you get immediate
feedback on your changes.
And you're more addressing
the deployment story,
which today probably
will be more
about generating JavaScript.
But--
LARS BAK: It's a valid point.
You need to deploy
your application.
And by no means, we don't
want to fragment the web.
So it's important that when
you translate that code
into JavaScript, it'll work
on all the modern browsers.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So let's
drill down just a
little bit on this.
How good of a job are
you actually doing
generating the JavaScript?
How big, how efficient is the
code that's being generated?
KASPER LUND: So
the generated code
is getting very, very good.
So we measure performance
of the generated code
and the size of the
code, check it over time.
And we've made lots
of good improvements
there, to a point
where generated
JavaScript code emitted
from the Dart to JS compiler
is as efficient as handwritten
code for a lot of cases.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And I probably
should have mentioned that
you guys are performance guys.
You've been working
on Hotspot, on V8,
and the goal every
time was really
to enable a new
class of applications
because the speed
was so much faster.
KASPER LUND:
Performance is good.
People tend to like it.
It's easy that way.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Perfect.
LARS BAK: One thing I
should add about performance
is that if you increase
performance in a platform,
you enable a new
class of applications
to run on a platform.
And that certainly
happened on the web,
where over the last five years,
performance of the browser
has just went through the roof.
And suddenly, you see very
complex and very animated
applications running on the web.
And this is just
due to performance.
When you give performance to
programmers, they'll use it.
KASPER LUND: Especially
if you give them
like 100 times
performance improvement.
That really changes the game.
Things that you
couldn't build before
are suddenly possible to build.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So this is 1.0,
and you guys are talking
performance already?
KASPER LUND: Why not?
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
No, great.
I think it's a great feature.
Performance is always
a great feature.
It tends to be a
1.1 or 2.0 feature.
In this case, it's not.
LARS BAK: I think Kasper forgot
to mention the Dart VM we have.
We also have a VM for Dart.
It's running twice as
fast as JavaScript.
So it's not too bad.
It's a good starting point.
And we expect that over
the next year or two
to dramatically
increase the speed,
both on the translated code
to JavaScript, but also
on the native implementation.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So the end result
is web applications.
But not only you can
go-- we'll probably
talk about where else
you can use Dart.
But who is this
really targeted at?
What kind of developers?
Is it JavaScript
developers today,
web developers, maybe service
side, trying to get into--
KASPER LUND: There's a lot
of interest from people that
actually have a
background in Java, C#,
that want to try to find a
good way of using their skills
on the web for
building web apps.
We certainly see a lot of
people interested there.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So worth mentioning probably
is the optional typing.
LARS BAK: Optional typing
is interesting in that you
can start out doing prototyping
without being bothered
by the types.
When you then get your
structure into your program,
you can start adding
static types in your APIs.
So at least all the
teams that use your code
can see how it should be used.
KASPER LUND: Yes,
documenting the intent
of your code makes
a ton of sense
when you're working with people.
LARS BAK: And it also makes
it much more readable.
So given that you're serious
about doing web applications,
your applications will
survive for a long time,
and you need to maintain
that and refactor it.
And the more intent you have
specified in the program,
the easier it is to
maintain over time.
KASPER LUND: A
simple description
of that is that we
found that people that
use Dart for writing web apps
have an easier time actually
taking a sample and
understanding what it does
and finding relevant
documentation from the type
annotations than people
that start from JavaScript.
Because you don't have
the types in there
to tell you what to look
for in the documentation.
So it's really helpful.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So other than types,
it has everything you'd
expect from a modern language,
so packages built in,
lambdas, all of those things.
You want to talk about
maybe syntactic sugar?
You've mentioned you've done
a demo during the keynote.
KASPER LUND: Sure.
So we try not to add too
much syntactic sugar.
But sometimes, you just
want to express your code
in a concise, nice way,
without repeating yourself
over and over again.
So we've added a few
things that make it easier
to construct objects in
a simple and sane way
without repeating the field
names and the parameter names
all over the place, like it's
common in some other languages.
So we've done a lot of
things to just cut down
on the boilerplate.
So we like to call it a
ceremony-free language.
You don't have to write tons of
code just to get your stuff up
and running.
LARS BAK: And the feedback
from the products that
are using Dart so far
has been that it's
more compact than Java,
and it's very readable.
So, so far, it looks good.
It seems like we've
hit the sweet spot
for what people are expecting.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: What's
quite impressive, I think, is
that you guys have pretty much
started building a real
community around it.
So because you have
package management,
you have people
contributing those libraries
in the form of packages.
You have people using
it, early adopters.
So tell me more
about the community
and how it's been
used, and maybe what's
Google's interest in all this.
And is Google even using
Dart or planning to use it?
LARS BAK: Of course
they're using Dart.
So this is not a toy project.
We're doing it for real.
And we're serious about making
it a good platform for writing
scalable web applications.
One thing you have to bear
in mind, before we have Dart,
you would find big
web projects that
were using JavaScript
plus comments, where
the types were put in comments.
And you would, based
on these comments,
try to figure out how the
program was stitched together.
And we're just
taking the extra step
in making a language
that supports that.
So for applications
that are large
and where you have several teams
working on the same code base,
this is a huge step forward.
And of course, you
know that Google
is having a lot of big web apps.
And we are serious
about making sure
that we can maintain
these web apps over time.
So yes, you will in the future
see applications written
in Dart from Google, as
well as from the outside,
which is important.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So there's at least one
that's publicly talked about
and Brad Green from the Android
team was up on
stage talking about.
How to build an
application with--
was it a team of
10, 12 developers
in less than six months?
And none of them actually
knew neither Angular nor Dart.
LARS BAK: So this is
the interesting part.
We have been very conservative
in designing the programming
language so that if you had
a background in a programming
language like C# or Java,
you could easily transition
into using Dart without
having any surprises.
So one of our core goals when
designing the programming
language was there was no
surprises when using it.
We would like to have each
construct in the language
be as natural to
understand as possible,
so no magic was
happening to the program.
I think that that
is key to make sure
that people like the
programming language.
KASPER LUND: Like returning
to your point about packages
and community around
Dart, it was very nice
for us to be able
to give a keynote.
And the demo that we
wanted to show in there
was actually based on
third party, you could say,
community code built by
someone outside our team,
just using the Dart platform.
And it's an excellent
set of libraries
we have out there that way.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So Angular is very popular.
Tell me more about
the work you've
done with the Angular team.
LARS BAK: So the
Angular guys decided
to make a Dart
version of Angular.
And that's a great
way to write apps,
a framework for
writing web apps.
But in all the logic in the
program, you just specify Dart.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And then what kind of benefit
do they expect from that?
And are they getting it already?
KASPER LUND: Well,
they're getting
some of the same benefits
as everybody else that's
writing in Dart-- more
structure to your code.
It's easier to
document your intent.
Everything's built for writing
larger, maintainable apps.
And you certainly get
that, even in a setting
where you're using Angular Dart.
So there's really no
difference between Dart
and Angular Dart in that space.
Angular solves the
problem of data binding
and those things, in the
Angular way, you could say.
And then Dart takes
care of making sure
that your application can scale
up and in the basic constructs
that it provides.
LARS BAK: So if you like the
nice bindings they provide
in Angular, then you can
use Angular Dart, together
with all the logic written in
Dart, and it works just great.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
So you can use Dart
to build web apps.
Can you use it for command
line, service side?
Does it even make sense-- it's
a general purpose language,
so you should be
able to do that.
LARS BAK: It's a general
purpose programming language.
And we already have
applications that
are written outside the browser.
One should mention the Dart
to JS command line tool.
It's a compiler that takes Dart
code and produces JavaScript.
Of course it's written in Dart.
KASPER LUND: And of course,
it can compile itself.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Of course.
LARS BAK: Oh yeah.
So you can compile the Dart
to JS compiled from Dart to JS
and run on top of a JavaScript
engine, if you like that.
KASPER LUND: If you're
interested in that sort
of thing.
LARS BAK: But that's
probably beyond the point.
But this is one
example where we have
scaled Dart to run
outside the browser.
So that works really well.
Another one is that we have
a performance tracking server
system inside to track our
increase in performance.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
That's server side.
LARS BAK: It's all
written in Dart.
And that's been running stable
for one and a half years now.
So it even works
outside the browser.
KASPER LUND: It does.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Very nice.
LARS BAK: And there's
more to come here.
But I think it's important to
focus on web applications now.
This is the first
area where we are
trying to have consistent
libraries and so forth.
And when that all
works well, we'll
be happy to expand outside.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Yeah, let's focus on that.
Let's do that really well.
So you guys have had
a lot of experience
in virtual machines,
Hotspot, V8.
What were the challenges
with Dart VM specifically?
KASPER LUND: It's
sort of designed
to be less
challenging, you could
say, than many of
the other things.
We know, from from
ground up, how VMs work.
So that helps when you
design the language
that you're trying to avoid
some of the pitfalls that
make it really
hard to implement.
So we tried to
make a design that
allows us to make it
go really, really fast.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LARS BAK: We designed it to
make it easier for the VM
implementer.
So one thing that we have been
bothered by in our systems
is that it's very
hard to predict
the performance
of an application.
So the Dart programming
language has
been designed so
that we can predict
how well it performs on the VM.
So the programmer,
when writing a program,
he can sort of estimate
how fast it runs.
And this is great.
KASPER LUND: It's basically
all about avoiding
performance pitfalls.
If you fall off that performance
cliff in too many weird ways,
it makes it really
hard to reason
about the performance
of your code.
LARS BAK: So for instance,
to give a contrast
to make it more
concrete, in JavaScript,
you know you can use an object
as a dictionary, basically.
And if you, from
the side, get hold
of an object inside
an application
and start messing with it,
suddenly the whole application
runs slow.
And that cannot happen in Dart.
So we designed it in such a
way that that's not possible.
And I think that will
be great for developers,
because they can predict how
well the code runs and should
not try to sort of guess
whether it runs fast
on one platform or the other.
So this is good.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So performance, by the way,
is not just the
app running fast.
It's also about the
app starting fast.
In the web, that actually
makes a lot of sense.
So there's work, I
understand, around that
in the Dart VM in
terms of fast startup.
Do you want to talk about that?
LARS BAK: Yeah,
we have snapshots.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Snapshots.
LARS BAK: So snapshots
is a simple mechanism
where you basically
start up the program
until you're about
to execute main.
And at that point, you
take the whole heap
and stabilize it and put it
into a binary format on the file
system.
And you can use that
as a starting point
when you start the application.
And easily, you get a factor
of 10 in startup performance.
That means that if your
application would take a second
to start up, now it's
only 100 milliseconds.
And as soon as the Dart
VM appears in Chrome,
then you will hopefully
see a very snappy startup
of web applications.
Right now, we're
using these snapshots
when starting up
Dart to JS to make
sure the tools have a fast
startup in our tool box.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
So when can we--
are you starting
to talk to the Chrome
guys to get in?
Of course, you have a Chromium
build with the Dart VM, which
is what you mentioned for
the development cycle.
Next step is
obviously to make it
available to as many
people as possible.
And people will just realize
that the app is running faster,
right?
LARS BAK: Precisely.
You can think about the
Dart VM inside the browser
as an accelerator.
So if it's not there, it'll take
off the [INAUDIBLE] version.
Talking to the Chrome guys--
we are the Chrome guys.
We are working on
the Chrome team.
So of course.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Well, I'm
sure you need to do some
convincing before it happens.
LARS BAK: The technology speaks.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
For itself.
KASPER LUND: It does.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Wonderful.
Well, on that note,
congratulations again
on that 1.0 release.
Where should people
go to try it out?
LARS BAK: Dartlang.org.
Try it out.
Send us some feedback.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
There you go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LARS BAK: --for you guys.
So hopefully you like it.
And send us feedback so
we can improve our system.
KASPER LUND: That's it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Thank you guys.
LARS BAK: Thank you.